this week's videos are sponsored by expressvpn
more on them after the reaction people citizens
of the reject Nation it is time to watch the
trailer dose for easily the most anticipated
comic book movie of the year sure to be
box office Behemoth number 20 Aquaman and
the lost kingdom John how are you I'm good
G how are you doing well this is Jason mimos
confirmed himself on the tonight show his
last time he's going to be playing Aquaman
who knows what else he's going to be doing
in the DC Universe afterwards no one has a
clue anywh who guys leave a like on this
video let's see what's going on in this
trailer hi baby boy talking to the fishies you and
me we're different that aqu we're connected to the
land and the sea I can't wait to introduce you
to all the Majestic creatur our planet look at
him an or just kicking this will can be yeah you
and me whoa where's his wife I'm going to kill
Aquaman damn even if I have to make a
deal with the devil to do it free me
from my prison there's that James one I'd
like will be yours the key to this prison
is the Royal bloodline itself because here
they are he needs us we're The End Of The
Bloodline no we're not uhoh he's your kid oh no
I bet his mom's going to be upset about that J he
must be stopped oh [__] they're going to totally
kill that kid he's got your baby I'm coming for
you destroy everything he holds de you want
bloody come get it damn he does some really
intense in this one oh aquam and the lost kingdom
oh [__] dude we got to go for Christmas day in
the theaters on Christmas for Aquaman too I'm not
going to lie I actually like that trailer more
than the last one yeah that was my first thought
was this actually looks like a really cool movie
oh man yeah oh wait wait wait who hold on you
know I just was thinking the fact that we are
using the internet right now to watch this trailer
someone might be trying to get our secrets so big
thanks to express vpm for sponsoring this video
a real game changer I've been using for years
that's right years so whenever they want to work
with us it's an instant yes you've likely heard
about expressvpn for online privacy and security
but there's more to it than that however there
was a very real incident recently with Spectrum
Shing down my internet and contacting me due to
a suspecting hacking attemp and funny enough
I realized I hadn't actually activated my
expressvpn on my new laptop that I got a couple
of months ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on YouTube a
couple years ago that made expressvpn my go-to for
both security and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this channel knows
you can use expressvpn to watch movies and shows
on Netflix that are not available in your country
this means accessing a vast rate of content of
over a 100 countries like a global cinema at your
fingertips it's super easy open Express VPN switch
refresh the browser and there you have it whether
it's kdramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I
player YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered
and it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience so
if you want to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you can get
an extra 3 months of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to expressvpn.com
reject to learn more thank you again I actually
thought that trailer zeroed in a lot more on a lot
more personal intensity you know the setup of like
I really love my my baby I'm not a single dad but
for some reason pretend like what happened she
can't afford to come on the L to this one even
though she spent the first one on l i I don't know
why Warner Brothers would be hiding the wife at
all makes no sense to me what's going on I'm sure
the comments are not at all talking about that the
visuals they actually even though the trailer is
shorter the the the visuals actually popped a lot
better to me you got more of that dark aesthetic
I like some of that like icy stuff that we were
seeing seems like the baby going to die or the dad
no be the baby cuz he's talking about looking for
the last um The Last Of The Bloodline the last of
the bloodline be his baby and in the last half of
this trailer he just seems like freaking Furious
yeah man he's got to fight for his progyny we're
going to see a dead baby in this room this is
going to be it's going to end darkest note that
zoom out from the ocean one BS to the surface
and then we zoom out to reveal that it's just all
babies just all over the surface of the sea jeez
it's going to be James ju's dead baby movie well
I mean I thought I thought Manta was in the F in
the trailer for the first one like w Yaya is like
I think one of the best actors around right now
it just kind of felt repetitive of the last one
but the the the Menace portrayed even though Again
trailer being shorter I felt it more everything
was just more about a feeling and while and it
seemed like it did expand in the the locations
of what we saw seemed like we are going to some
darker terrain it does seem like we are going
to some darker terrain here and not just physic
physically but emotionally for our characters this
time so I I did feel like unlike the last trailer
I did get something different here that did Feel
Again more personal yeah yeah yeah it's weird I I
think this was a great choice to to compact should
have been the first trailer it really should have
because now we know I mean like the first trailer
gives us the sense that like orm and and uh you
know Arthur Arthur are going to bond and they're
going to go on this adventure together and they're
going to do some Indiana Jones stuff and like you
could have done that here like you know that isn't
very apparent from this but yeah just the idea
that like he's got his son uh it's very dear at
the beginning I love that whole thing where he's
talking about like oh soon all the you know Simba
someday all this going to be yours uh and and then
to do the flip instead of Mufasa dying Simba
exactly and then him and Scar got to team up
that's right 100% they got to go take on uh hyena
or whoever else fits the lion kinging metaphor but
yeah like it's a personal seter got to go get Bob
IG for him to worry about uh yeah and then this is
a very Universal motivation for why the adventure
will start but we know that the adventure is going
to have all the dazzling crazy visuals that we've
come to expect from Aquaman and I liked that you
do still have you know these what looks to be
you know like trench dwellers and stuff that
can at least alleviate the pain of losing the
trench movie yeah and you've got that guy who
comes up the the the first guy they talk to who
I don't know exactly what his character is but
he looks like the dun Harrow king or something he
looks like the the king of the Dead Army and the
Lord of the Rings and even the way he moves kind
of had this like stop motion esque flavor to it
so I'm excited to see what kind of like Ray Harry
how and tributing they do with those characters um
yeah CU it seems like they're they're leaning more
into the fantasy side of it where in the first
movie because there's like oh we have the rules of
the world and there's like uh the Sci-Fi element
of atlantans that are atlantans atlantans Atlant
which there's no T at the at it is atlantans not
atlantans okay so it's they have the atlanteans
are we sure about that in America we just dull
out the te so I think either one is acceptable
I didn't bring attention to it I think people
are either saying atlans or atlantans basically
so atlantans is fine all right okay so with the
Atlantis kind of folks that in the last movie like
while they did have some of that Fantastical lore
that they lean into is more of the rules of we
have atlantans who live underwater they breathe
underwater and stuff but in terms of the mysticism
of Destiny and and and more that Lord of the Rings
type of fantasy s quality that to to lean into
that I think is probably a smarter call to do this
time around yeah or or just pee on it yeah just
pee on it um guys what did you think about this
trailer did do you like it is the dialogue working
for you sure it's just as cheesy as always what
are you going to do I mean it's the first it's
a sequel to the first one but I I like this one
this one actually I thought it was a much better
trailer yeah I was surprised by it and they took
out the one shot of Amber herd so that we would
all forget that che's even we forgot I'm sure
the comments are not talking all about it nope
never all right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below thank you to expressvpn for sponsoring
and we will catch you all very very [Music] soon